j'ai galéré comme un fou pour essayer de
remonter ma boîte parce que vous
imaginez bien monsieur Véran qu'à un
moment donné quand vous investissez dans
une nouvelle entreprise vous mettez de
ce que vous avez puis les économies que
vous avez forcément vous les mettez sur
la table moi j'avais plus rien mais d'un
petit peu d'aide c'est pas de l'aide que
je demandais je demandais mon droit de
travailler une chose à 25 % j'aurais
même pas eu besoin de vous aider parce
que si on calcule bien dans l'absolu à
25 millions par jour même sur 7 sur 7 ça
me dérangeait pas de travailler je
continue de payer mes charges je
continue de payer mes employés je
continue de vivre et donc d'engranger la
trésorerie ce qui paraît normal on est
d'accord ça vous m'avez pas laissé faire
mais pas laisser faire mais dit c'est
tout le monde 10000 d'accord même le mec
a pas besoin il prenait 10000 puis après
les VGE c'était 25% du PGE d'accord que
l'État a garanti vous avez déposé
quelque chose quelque part en termes de
garantie parce que 90000 euros pour moi
Cyril ça fait 25% de mon chiffre
d'affaires de l'époque bien sûr
25% de mon chiffre d'affaires de
l'époque aujourd'hui vous avez mis sur
la table 140 milliards d'euros de
millions d'euros pardon excuse-moi un
milliard d'euros
milliards d'euros ces milliards d'euros
aujourd'hui ce sont nous les français
qui payons aujourd'hui il faut savoir
qu'il y a 49 % de faillites
supplémentaires en 2022 dans
l'hôtellerie restauration c'est PGE là
qui va les payer ça c'est ma première
question ma deuxième question c'est
quand est-ce que moi vous me remboursez
sur ma perte personnelle parce que vous
me demandez de rembourser un PGE et des
charges à ne plus savoir qu'en faire je
paye 30 % matière en plus depuis 2019
vous connaissez le prix du litre du
fioul monsieur Véran en fuel domestique
pour se chauffer
0 64 centimes 2022 1,54 je mange 8000
balles de fioul par an je suis au gaz
monsieur Véran combien je paye à votre
avis vous avez une idée de prix du gaz
vous avez une idée de ce qu'on paye et
nous artisans artisan mais de
merde je suis en train de faire un
million d'euros je dégage 75 de marge
brute 42% de ma salariale il me reste
rien et quand il me reste vous me prenez
encore 25%. je vois pas mes gosses
pendant des mois parce qu'il faut que je
travaille en cuisine j'en chie comme un
veau mes employés sont là il lâche rien
merci à ma clientèle d'être là
franchement merci franchement je suis je
trouve ça aberrant qu'aujourd'hui vous
venez sans présenter d'excuses au
français je trouve ça lamentable
n'oubliez pas attendez n'oubliez pas ici
nous sommes les employeurs de l'État
vous travaillez pour nous parce qu'avec
mes charges attendez excusez-moi je vois
tous les jours à la télé c'est bon
laisse-moi parler 2 secondes
je vais expliquer comment donner les
choses doivent être dites parce que
toutes mes charges vous en faites quoi
toutes les chartes je paye sur les
salaires sur les infos indirects qui est
la TVA d'accord en 20 et à 10%. je donne
170000 euros de TVA par an j'ai donné
400000 euros de ma salariale brut bien
sûr
il me reste rien vous nous prenez tout
tout le temps puis après on dirait il
faut donner le patron vaut mieux payer
vous savez combien on paye un plongeur
chez nous tu verras vous avez une idée
c'est 1500 euros nourri logé net net je
vous garantis ça c'est pour la plonge
plus les heures supplémentaires un
serveur c'est 2000 € j'habite à cuzange
un tout petit village de 70 habitants je
suis pas à Paris moi d'accord donc on
n'a pas forcément les moyens d'ailleurs
laissez-moi vous dire que Paris c'est la
capitale de la France et ça ne
représente pas toute la France nous
sommes des 1000 multitudes de communes
une multitude d'artisans donc je ne
parle que sur que pour mon nom Cyril
mais je voudrais vraiment vous dire ma
colère contre l'État aujourd'hui qui va
peut-être me mettre en faillite pourquoi
Monsieur varan parce qu'à un moment
donné j'ai travaillé d'accord après la
reprise du covid j'ai bossé on a
travaillé une super année d'ailleurs
c'est à dire fait beau c'est top je me
suis parce qu'on avait une périnée de
personnel j'ai créé une école avec Marie
Dufay en prison de Région Bourgogne
Franche-Comté le GRETA de Besançon qui
m'a super bien aidé pour qu'on mette en
place
des gens pour les remettre au boulot des
gens qui étaient sans emploi sans
formation de 18 à 60 ans donc je me suis
cassé la tête j'ai pas baissé les bras
aujourd'hui je baisse les bras quand
j'aurai vendu ou si je lis pas avant je
prendrai l'argent que j'ai géré le
dépenser ailleurs vous verrez plus puer
un euro de ma poche je continuerai de
payer il me reste 3 ans à payer dans 3
ans je quitte ce pays parce que j'espère
que tout le monde fera ça parce qu'à un
moment donné ce pays attends Nicolas
Sarkozy a dit quand la France quand tu
l'aimes pas tu la quittes c'est vrai ou
pas ben moi je dis que quand la France
n'aime plus ces artisans ses artisans de
se quitter le pays ça c'est une vérité
c'est pas dangereux si vous aujourd'hui
le cancer de ce pays c'est pas nous nous
on bosse si vous vraiment vous aimiez la
France Monsieur Véran à tous
les sénateurs et tous les ministres où
travaillaient au SMIC au SMIC pas un
euro de plus comme ça vous comprendrez
ce que ces gens là tout cela vivent
parce qu'avec 1300 balles aujourd'hui tu
veux pas et moi patron de de 25 salariés
dans la dans l'absolu moi pour vous
Stéphane ça fait 6 mois que j'ai pas
pris de salaire si moi j'ai pas pris un
salaire je vous montre mon compte
bancaire mon téléphone je vous le
montrerai sur les yeux j'ai pas 1 €
j'ai travaillé comme un Forza il
me reste rien alors me dites pas à me
parler pas de vos aides au niveau de
l'État par rapport à l'électricité ça
vaut rien ça vaut rien parce que
concrètement vous appeler il y a
personne au bout du fil hein d'accord si
vous êtes à 49% d'augmentation vous avez
sert à rien
ne droit rien si vous faites plus d'un
million de chiffre d'affaires rien
d'accord donc les aides de quoi on peut
même les charges vous savez que si vous
reportez votre PG aujourd'hui
concrètement j'ai appelé mon banquier
parce qu'on s'entend bien c'est un mec
super on s'appelle 17 je suis désolé je
peux pas je peux pas t'aider parce que
si je te reporte un petit coup de pêche
ne serait-ce qu'une année vous voyez ce
que je veux dire parce que maintenant
deux ans de covid on la reporté les PGE
qui devaient durer sur 6 ans maintenant
il dure que sur quatre on a commencé
enclencher les PG c'est une fortune ça
moi pour moi c'est 1800 balles par mois
en plus donc c'est 18000 euros quasiment
par an donc ça me coûte une fortune un
moment donné j'explique j'ai pas la
structure qui a 25 ans comme marque qui
est imposé depuis des années moi il y a
trois ans que j'achète resto mais on
nous a pas laissé respirer ni pendant le
covid ni après le covid on a le PGE sur
la tête d'accord on a la tête sous l'eau
concrètement avec les
tout a flamber comment on fait pour s'en
sortir monsieur Véran comment alors
d'abord je vois que vous êtes en colère
non mais quel point je suis en colère je
l'imagine vous savez j'en ai vu d'autres
et je vois que vous êtes en colère et je
critique pas les raisons de votre colère
et je pense que parmi ce que vous avez
dit il y a des trucs je vous respecte
monsieur vera en tant que je suis pas
sûr tu respectes
pas la fonction je ne ferai jamais même
empire ennemi d'accord donc quand vous
dites que je suis le cancer de machin
non c'est une image non si vous
respectez les gens ça veut dire que vous
apprenez aussi à ce que je crois que
depuis je suis ici depuis le bonheur
Cyril je crois que je me défile pas
derrière les questions j'ai passé
sélectionné les gens qui viennent ici ce
soir j'ai empêché personne de venir
d'ailleurs ce soir sur ce plateau et
donc je suis je viens ici pour qu'on
puisse débattre et discuter
tranquillement donc moi je n'utiliserai
jamais la victime et j'utiliserai jamais
des injures ni merde ni et bien sûr
[Musique]
il y a plein de raisons pour lesquelles
vous avez le droit d'être en colère et
je remets pas en question ça je dis
juste pour qu'on puisse avoir une
discussion ça veut dire une discussion
c'est à deux je vous ai écouté
maintenant je vais essayer de vous
parler un peu
il y a des choses pour lesquelles vous
êtes exprimé ou je peux être d'accord
sur le poids des charges quand on ouvre
un restaurant sur le poids la masse
salariale les complexités
administratives vous pouvez vous
retrouver la tête sous l'eau je ne doute
pas une seconde que vous soyez un
bosseur que vous auriez pas de 15 mars
je ne doute pas une seconde que la nuit
quand vous essayez de dormir vous
pensiez au compte et que ça vous empêche
de dormir etc non mais donc je peux
parfaitement contre ça et le niveau de
stress dans lequel vous êtes je peux
l'entendre d'accord ok les trucs sur
lesquels on tombera pas d'accord mais on
n'est pas là c'est pas le c'est pas pour
ça que vous m'interrogez ce soir sur la
gestion de crise covid je vous avais le
droit c'est votre votre opinion mais
vous avez le devoir de respecter la loi
et vous l'avez respecté puisque vous
avez fermé le restaurant et l'État en
retour là c'est là où je suis pas
d'accord je vois beaucoup de
restaurateurs je vais dans beaucoup de
restos dans beaucoup de barres dans
beaucoup de commerce ou en général les
gens disent ça a été compliqué mais vous
nous avez aidé vous nous avez aidé et
vous avez été là et de fait Stéphane il
y a pas beaucoup de restaurants qui ont
fermé suite à l'épisode du covid et la
fermeture imposée pour des raisons
sanitaires il faut ce que vous dites
regardez les chiffres alumi mais en fait
c'est en fait j'ai rencontré très simple
j'ai rencontré d'abord j'ai rencontré
Thierry Marx les nouveaux patrons de lui
il y a trois semaines vous voyez donc on
a discuté ensemble on a fait le point
sur le nombre de restaurants avant la
crise après la crise et les difficultés
la grosse difficulté qui aujourd'hui que
doivent affronter aujourd'hui les
restaurateurs vous l'avez un peu dit et
vous avez une solution qui montre que
vous êtes débrouillard c'est la capacité
à recruter c'est trouver du personnel
vous l'avez dit vous-même vous avez
augmenté sans doute le salaire de votre
plongeur vous avez augmenté les salaires
de votre serveur moi la personne et
alors les serveurs ils vous diront
qu'ils ont pas le choix que de demander
une hausse de salaire parce que c'est
compliqué pour eux parce qu'ils sont
obligés de faire du travail haché qui
partent très tard c'est leur coûte cher
en transport etc donc de fait le marché
a évolué et on a besoin aussi d'adapter
la formation des jeunes vers les métiers
pour lesquels on peut recruter et il se
trouve que la restauration c'est de fait
un vrai métier en gros tension et que
c'est la galère pour les restaurateurs
vous le savez vous avez ça je trouve ça
très bien vous avez manifestement créé
avec la région vous avez cité Marie
guide du fait une école de formation
pour pouvoir former vos d'autres jeunes
qui pourront ensuite travailler dans vos
restaurants et les autres restaurants de
la région ce qui est très bien 250 000
postes en hôtellerie restauration
aujourd'hui
c'est aussi pour ça que les salaires
augmentent pour ça aussi que vos charges
augmentés c'est que aujourd'hui
on paye plus un serveur au SMIC il faut
en général augmenter le salaire surtout
quand on est dans des territoires ruraux
c'est difficile de trouver des jeunes
qui peuvent venir bosser dans la
restauration de fait et donc on veut
aussi accompagner à la fois en formant
davantage de gens pour aller dans les
métiers en tension et à la fois
continuer d'accompagner les commerçants
les restaurateurs pour que ça leur il ne
soit pas obligé de mettre la clé sous la
porte parce qu'ils ont pas de personnel
ou parce que ça leur coûte trop cher